you know the first case in the medical
literature uh there was a
classical schizophrenia
there was a patient named james tilly
matthews who
had this uh he sketched out for his
doctor the
uh experiences he was he was uh sensing
and he drew himself as a
a cowering figure on the ground
controlled
by a loom a weaving device that was
sending threads
long threads projections across space
from the loom to him to his arms and to
his body and controlling him
from afar
and he called this the heirloom
a loom in the air
and
it was such an evocative thing because
you know this was the start of the
industrial revolution or mid and it was
where you know
really industrial strength
you know looms and weaving devices were
really uh kind of the
emblematic of the most
complex
powerful technological achievements of
the time and so that was the explanation
available to him to explain how
his body was seemingly moved without his
volition uh
and these days of course people with
schizophrenia will have more
technology appropriate interpretations
they'll
have a you know delusions of satellite
or alien control or or beamed
information very very common to have
this delusion of
a government agency
you know sending electromagnetic or or
radio frequency information to control
their limbs
but it's it's the same thing it's that
whether it's a thread from an industrial
revolution loom
or
you know rf you know radiation it's the
same thing just adapted to the to the
moment explaining trying to explain the
world they live in in their relationship
to the world but unconstrained by sort
of
the thing that's socially acceptable
which is that's right both refreshing
and dangerous yes
you